Definitely do not get sucked into the
mindset that these things are inherently
top heavy or front end costly or
anything.
It's absolutely not true.
It was possible to do it much more
efficiently than a lot of people told us
was the case.
When we surveyed the landscape of what
was out there in this particular sector,
even of it stuff,
and we dug around a little to sort of
investigate what kind of costs labor,
what goes into this.
We were pretty stunned to find out what
people were spending on the front end to
engineer these things,
put them up.
We had a really hard time figuring out
what people were spending all that money
on to create,
we think very bad products.
What is possible for a young person with
an idea in terms of executing it today
even more than five years ago,
certainly more than 10 years ago in
terms of the speed with which you can
engineer things,
the software that's available in an open
source way for you to construct these
things.
Suffice to say,
I think if people knew what it took,
what it costs us to set crowdrise up,
they'd be staggered.
I think it's like fractional compared to
some of the other big name things that
you've heard about.